lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
introducirnos a la idea de la regla del
cociente de la regla del cociente y esta
vez no voy a hacer la demostración pero
en algún vídeo próximo voy a hacer a
detalle la demostración como veremos
tiene muchas similitudes con la regla
del producto aquí vamos a aprender un
poco sobre qué es la regla del cociente
cuánto y cómo aplicarla así que por
ejemplo si tengo una función f x que
pueda expresar como el cociente de dos
funciones
supongamos de ode x
entre b de x entonces lo que nos dice la
regla del cociente es que f prima de x y
tal vez en un principio te sea un poco
complicada pero una vez que lo apliques
seguramente te sentirás mucho más cómodo
con ella bueno esto va a ser igual a la
derivada del numerador es decir una
prima de x
por la función del denominador es decir
vdx menos la función del número es decir
de x por la derivada de la función del
denominador es decir b prima de x ya
está aquí observa se parece bastante a
la regla del producto cuando tenemos fx
igual a de x por vez de x la derivada
queda muy parecida sólo que en lugar de
tener un signo negativo aquí en la regla
del producto hay un signo positivo pero
con la regla del cociente todavía no
hemos terminado porque esto hay que
dividirlo entre la función del
denominador elevada al cuadrado es decir
vete x esto elevado al cuadrado bien
ahora qué te parece si aplicamos esta
idea que acabamos de construir digamos
que fx es igual a la función x cuadrada
entre el coseno de x
lo primero que será bueno preguntarnos
es quién es ud x y quiénes ve de x bueno
nuestra de x va a ser x cuadrada así que
pondré que esté aquí es mi de x y por lo
tanto un prima de x va a ser simplemente
2 x bien y quienes ve de x el coseno de
x va a ser vdx y por lo tanto b prima de
x es la derivada del coseno de x que es
el menos seno de x ahora si solo
apliquemos lo que tenemos acá arriba
basándonos en eso voy a tener que f
prima de x es igual y primero tengo la
derivada de la función del número 2 que
es 2x
esto por la función del denominador que
es coseno de x
menos
la función del número 2 que es x
cuadrada por la derivada de la función
del denominador la derivada del coseno
de x es el menos seno de x entonces por
el menos seno de x y todo esto dividido
entre la función del denominador al
cuadrado es decir coseno cuadrado de x
yo también lo puedo escribir como el
coste de x esto elevado al cuadrado
de hecho dejan dejarlo así para que sea
más claro y el llegar a este punto
simplemente tenemos que simplificar esto
va a ser igual
bueno tengo 2x por el coseno de x
y aquí tengo negativo por negativo lo
cual es positivo
entonces me va a quedar más x cuadrada
por el seno de x
todo esto entre el coseno cuadrado de x
que ahora podemos escribir así coseno
cuadrado de x ya hemos acabado podrías
intentar simplificar un poco más pero la
nuestra no vio que se simplifica
bastante así que en el futuro vamos a
aprender algo que se llama la regla de
la cadena y es importante mencionar que
también hay una forma de ver esta regla
del cociente usando la regla del
producto y la regla de la cadena pero si
todavía no conoces la regla de la cadena
esta expresión sobre la regla del
cociente te va a ser muy útil nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo